la conférence a inspiré des
restaurateurs écologistes au menu des
recettes bonne pour le climat
gaëtan berthelot chef à la table des
anges rien donné 2 kg 5 de co2 pour un
repas et l'idée c'est de diviser au
moins par deux ce chiffre
pour y arriver les restaurateurs réunis
sous le nom bon pour le climat le
cuisine que des aliments de saison et
qui ne viennent pas de trop loin pas non
plus l'aliment cultivées dans les serres
qu'il faut chauffer des produits locaux
qui émettent moins ceux de leurs du
transport et des produits à majorité
végétal puisque les végétaux génère
beaucoup moins de gaz à effet de serre
que les que l'avion n'est plats sont
identifiés à l'aide de ce petit logo sur
le menu
mais ce que cela influence vraiment le
choix du client direct lollll halak
obtient peut être l'occasion de
comprendre certaines choses nouvelles
mais je ne pense pas pouvoir dire que
quand je mange quelque chose de soi chez
moi ou au bureau je m'intéresse
exactement à sa valeur carbone
le regroupement ne compte encore que 32
restaurant la plupart à paris où il y en
a plus de 6000 haut